look I am just a guy that sent in an
anonymous you know nobody emailed to
op-ed in New York Times I have been
published in one literary magazine I'd
been working on a book that nobody was
eager to read and out of the blue I sent
it to New York Times and one day they
kind of came in and plucked me out of
anonymity and said hey this is a big
story but when they even told me that it
was going to be on The Times you know I
was shocked but then when I actually saw
it on the actual thing they threw it on
the front page and it was almost like
the world changed how can you be
surprised though about the way that
people responded you're throwing with
this with an op-ed like that it's like
throwing red meat to a pack of wild
animals well I'll tell you one thing
that I think is different about what I
wrote which is that I think the world is
full of a lot of smart people saying
smart things and usually their finger is
pointed at other people you guys are
doing this wrong you're pointing at
yourself I was saying look I was taking
accountability for my behavior and
saying I came to see that the way I was
acting was impacting people in a
negative way and I take responsibility
for it but it's Wall Street to blame for
that to say Wall Street doesn't do any
good is it really doing worse than lots
of other industries when I look at how
tons of industries get paid the media
industry the sports industry is Wall
Street really that much worse
should there be this awful populist
opinion first of all I am not blaming
anybody second of all I think this is a
way bigger thing than Wall Street I
think the response I got which came from
all over the world all different classes
of people is something cultural it's
about the red carpets on Hollywood it's
about the pro football players that make
all this money it's about this crazy
focus on the Mega Millions lottery all
the time but if you had been paid
the eight million bucks you thought you
should you wouldn't you should have been
paid that year would this have even
happened or would you be sitting here
silk sit in the front row of the Knicks
and going to the Super Bowl today no I
mean what I will say is that I was
working on my sort of spiritual issues
and my addiction issues for a long time
so right when I got to the point that I
was ready to leave Wall Street you know
it was a really scary thing but it was
where I was going I mean it was the
product of eight years of
work Sam what do you say to the folks
who are watching right now thinking to
themselves what a jerk right we had such
a good thing going the financial crisis
you know since the financial crisis okay
it's not so good anymore and to the
degree the PR department and the boards
of directors a little thing to sample
right now it's only going to get worse
what do you say to those you mean for
the Wall Street people yes your former
colleagues look at my ears out there
look I mean my story is just a story of
one guy and I'm saying that you know
when I was on Wall Street I used to
believe that the issue of whether I was
going to get paid 1 million or 2 million
was sort of the most critical thing in
the world and one of the things that I
came to see and not because I'm sort of
some moral hero or you know the most
honorable guy in the world but because I
came to a teacher that started teaching
me different things and I came to see
the world from a different perspective
and say hey you know whether or not
we're getting paid this much on Wall
Street is less important than people
that are actually really struggling out
there but Sam now here you are in the
media you're on TV you're writing a book
I mean an adrenalin addicts playground
so couldn't one argue babe you're doing
the same thing you're just doing it on a
bigger stage I tell you what there's two
things first of all I never expected
this but second or not you send an op-ed
to the New York Times and you didn't
expect it what did you think they were
gonna do with it well I thought they
would do what they did what I did what
had happened to me so many times before
that something I sent out got rejected
but you sent it with a goal when you go
up to bat you want to hit the homerun
when you get on the front page that's
the Homer I hear you it was a fortuitous
thing okay but this Stephanie's point
Sam you acknowledge being addicted to
money and before being addicted to money
you acknowledge being addicted to some
other things too can you not get
addicted to publicity just the same way
as you were addicted to money and the
way that money drove you to make bad
decisions publicity could drive you to
make bad decisions absolutely and you
know one of the things that I'm working
on right now literally is that I know
and I've come to believe that there is
nothing that I can do today tomorrow
yesterday that makes me more valuable
than I was when I was born so literally
this New York Times thing came out and
the world is sitting here saying hey Sam
your
interesting for your 15 minutes of fame
you're interesting and my challenge is
to say no I'm the same guy that I was
and I'm going to my focus is trying to
stay grounded and that's what I'm doing
Sam what do you think about the fact
that your peers so many people on Wall
Street who you respect who you work with
who I know they're mad about this what
do you think about that you know what
let me just say this that some of my
best friends are on Wall Street I'm
staying with my mentors and my mentors
house right now is funding your charity
a Wall Street guy definitely and I'll
tell you what if there's anybody in the
world that has taught me lessons about
generosity and kindness it is literally
that man who you know and and I love him
and frankly I love the people on Wall
Street and this idea that I'm talking
about we just see the people look I'm
saying that I am I was addicted to money
okay I'm saying that I was using money
and power to fill my soul okay that's
all I'm saying and however they take
that that's sort of their business okay
you don't think your piece was damaging
to their reputation I mean I read all
the comments it really seems like you
were waving a flag and people said
you're right
those Wall Streeters they suck and those
the guys have backed you Sam look I
understand what you're saying and I like
the people on Wall Street I thought my
story was really important to share out
there and I'm glad I did it a lot of
folks who still hold positions like that
Sam pull down big paychecks and bonuses
are very philanthropic
perhaps your mentor the guy you just
described who's helping to back your
nonprofit is a philanthropic guy I
haven't met him yet Stephanie knows him
well it seems to me through some more
than casual interaction at times that
those people justify the money they earn
by their philanthropy this philanthropy
make it okay for me it's you know that's
it's not about that you know I didn't
you know leave Wall Street in order to
start no no no I understand that you've
done something different but let me do
that for me I have
really have no judgment on the
individuals on Wall Street I'm not
asking whether to judge I'm just asking
it you know there's there's this Isle of
philanthropy we should all celebrate
philanthropy but does being
philanthropic make it okay to make more
dough than just about anybody else out
there I don't know I'm just asking you
guys when I'm in there and now you're
honestly think that you're asking a
question that requires a judgement all
I'm saying is that I came to understand
that I was trying to fill something
inside me with money and it was never
going to work and so what I realized was
that it wasn't about outside things it
wasn't about money or power or publicity
what I needed to do to fill this pain
inside me was to get help and I started
talking to a teacher and she started
teaching me things about handling myself
with integrity and speaking with honesty
and honor and when you look at the
explosion of Wall Street wealth in the
last ten years specifically in the hedge
fund universe given your perspective do
you think those people are just built in
a different way to get to that
billionaire status are you somewhere on
the sociopath Trek in your opinion yeah
in my opinion I believe that people that
are focusing on accumulating money in
the same way that I was at the expense
of everything else that there is
something that they're trying to fill
inside that there may be some spiritual
issue there and for those who want to
follow the track that you did is the
only answer to walk away because you did
have the benefit of having made all that
money you could walk away and reflect
and think and read there are people who
are teachers who hated coaches who think
it's awful and they don't have that
luxury Wall Street gave you that luxury
absolutely and I don't believe honestly
that it's about being on or off Wall
Street what it is it's about finding
balance and finding some sense of a core
identity or a core sense of strength
that says I'm valuable no matter how
much money I make no matter who I work
for no matter what my business card says
and however people need to get there if
that's what they choose that's what I
said but you think a super-rich person
can be balanced I do
sure absolutely